alors la télévision c'est un instrument
de quoi alors placement d'informations
pour les gens qui la regarde
et c'est quoi c'est un moyen de
d'enfermer le moyen femmes et légendes
entre la publicité les petits jeux les
plus vieux bébé tirons-nous et puis
d'être comme ça qu'ils te franchement
pas les informer sur moi je voudrais
surtout parler des jeux dibbets époque
choix très très intéressés par ces jeux
bébête mais il faut bien se dire que les
jeux bébêtes plaisent énormément motion
tout ce qui est bête plaît je sais pas
si vous savez à peu près le nombre de
gens qui aiment ces jeux qui aiment les
écouter en mangeant qui regardent la
télé en bouffant qui sont vraiment
concentrés là dessus mais vraiment c'est
invraisemblable est exactement pareil
que pour les variétés que maintenant les
jeunes m de moins en moins mais qui
place toujours aux vieux qui sont assis
dans leur fauteuil comme rien à faire
non ces trucs là ça plaît énormément et
tout le monde les demandes
donc je vois pas pourquoi parce que nous
ça nous plaît pas les passerait pas
évidemment ça ne plaît pas ça nous
embête mais il faut bien dire qu'il y en
a beaucoup et qui s'appelait faut
reconnaître qu'il ya des programmes qui
m'emballe pas du tout ça m'intéresse pas
du tout je vois un soir certaines
émissions bon je préfère rester dans mon
lit à lire ou à écouter la radio
c'est aux visions instrument de
propagande
je trouve que la télévision ne empêche à
certains contacts avec la famille par
exemple les gens qui le couple et les
enfants qui ne peuvent se voir seulement
un repas ils sont leur attention est
fixé par la télévision
aucun dialogue ne s'engagent pas entre
eux il avait son sont toujours fixés par
cette image qui ils reprochent beaucoup
la télévision c'est votre avis vous
l'avez la télé vidéo
non vous fâcher est ce que c'est être du
sang dure
ta famille maintenant qu'il n'ya plus la
télévision beaucoup mieux parce que j'ai
beaucoup plus de temps pour par exemple
je faisais vite mais tramon travail pour
aller voir la télévision ou alors puis
on mange beaucoup moins précipitée par
exemple pour l'estomac parler des films
j'ai eu la télévision on l'a pas
longtemps gardé pourquoi je pense que ma
petite soeur travailler plus ou alors ou
alors c'était tellement bête que vous
regardez pas et ne s'en servait de bain
c'était l'un ou l'autre
et puis à son et puis quand j'entends je
vais en vacances je suis quelqu'un qui à
la télévision
combien de fois j'ai vu les mêmes films
qui repasse et de ceux ci à la rtf
il ya des films qui sont rangé
soigneusement dans des casiers je suis
pauvre et on se sentait timbre repasser
des films comme ça de trois fois dans
l'année mais je trouve que c'est dingue
dans une émission qui vous serait
consacré cet axe est consacrée aux gens
de votre âge
qu'est-ce qu'on devrait y trouver moi je
crois que s'il y avait des émissions
dites culturelles fois qu'ils peuvent
qui peuvent apporter quelque chose dans
ceux qui les écoutent sur tous les plans
aussi des sur la musique que sur
l'histoire et qui peuvent les qui
peuvent être rendues intéressante quoi
évidemment le chantier serait l'idéal
la culture avant la distraction oui oui
les aimer les émissions pour les jeunes
ce qu'on appelle des émissions pour les
jeunes à mon avis et c'est vraiment se
moquer du monde conseil existe pas
on peut pas faire de démission si elles
sont culturelles on peut pas faire des
missions spécifiques pour des pour des
types de notre âge parce que je vois pas
pourquoi nous on n'aurait pas droit à
des émissions culturelles aussi
intéressante pour des pour des adultes
que pour nous par exemple je suis sûr
qu'il y aurait beaucoup d'adultes qui
qui aurait beaucoup besoin d'eux
venir dans nos classes pour apprendre
pas mal de choses dont je tire garde
c'est souvent à dire en moyenne de mopti
que tous les jours au louis tous les
jours les feuilletons pas pas tellement
parce que pour notre âge maintenant des
émissions c'est intéressant je crois
qu'ils en doutent et pensent qu'il
faudra en mettre un peu plus parce qu'il
y en a bien pour pour les plus petits il
y en a pour les plus grands mais pour
nous d'ailleurs pas grand chose
justement tu peux charteau l'importance
et citigroup 7 mois voire décision
d'avoir une émission que tu composerait
parce que toi qu'est-ce que tu mettrais
dans cette émission de variétés un plus
de deux cultures et bien déjà il y
aurait des émissions sur ce qu'on fait
en classe par exemple
résolution s'ils savent que dans cette
classe ont étudié telle pièce il pourra
nous passer des programmes une plaine où
passer la pièce bien un film qui est
passé de d'emile science pour la
jeunesse l'orientation pourront faire
plus tard parce que moi personnellement
j'ai pas demandé ce que je crois que
tard je mens bien comment que nous
aurions un peu ce que l'on peut faire ce
qu'on aime bien nos réserves faites côté
n'a pas que ce qui pourrait pas ce que
c'est bon je trouve que quand un ami il
faudrait quand même que tout le monde en
est une
seulement pour le regarder parfois le
soir pas tous les soirs
parce que je vais pas moi avant on
écoutait plus là de la musique par
exemple dans nicklas maintenant la
musique personne âgée de 9 ans
oui d'accord mais même moi la télévision
ça fait pas très longtemps que je lai et
puis avant que je ne lai on écoutait la
musique mais maintenant notre temps
collé à la télévision parce que vous
êtes auxiliaire pour la publicité oui
parce que pour la publicité dans le ce a
envoyé trois ou quatre marques de
produits pour laver de toute façon quand
on se promène dans la rue quand on va
faire des achats
on le voit nous mêmes de nos propres
mesures il ya des idées à des pancartes
partout alors je crois qu'à la télé
c'est indispensable
vraiment il ne faut pas trop en abuser
parce que premièrement ça enlève le goût
de lire et je trouve que sous 10 jours
c'est moi je pense que sans lui
n'auraient rien quand même parce que il
ya beaucoup de mes camarades conseillers
on a vu on a vu
film à la télévision ça y est mais je
trouve que n'arrive ya beaucoup plus de
détails très intéressants
la division pour toi elle doit être
absolument pas totalement pratiquement
distractives naturel actif avec lequel
elle a passé une bonne journée de
travail nettement la télévision sans
qu'on les émissions compliqué mais ce
que vous auriez sur en 8e par exemple
que l'émission en fait particulièrement
pour les gens voteraient oui j'ai
rarement quelque chose de pia finalement
ça ça va tourner à l'obsession
on voit que ça et ça étouffe un peu tout
ce qu'on peut faire conter c'est à dire
c'est pour cela tu la province à
seloncourt
entre tes parents et toi tu gagnes à la
télé et à +10 a fait quoi ça sert je
sais pas
pouvait parfois on est parfois tenté de
sacrifier quelque chose cette finale
quelque chose d'intéressant pour
regarder la télé tu refasses contact en
moins de choses tu trouve qu elles mêmes
ce masque à la semelle est mal fait ou
c'est parce que l'instrument télévision
lui même temps belle mais pour moi je
trouve que la télévision est bien faite
est un moyen de distraction
ça nous permet de vin vous informer de
ce qui nous entoure
mais c'est aussi les rdd des avantages
comme celui du à force de regarder la
télévision il ya une rupture totale avec
la famille ou avec le dialogue
alors qu'est-ce qu'on sauve le famille
ou la télévision deux amis
[Musique]